nueva jornada de paro nacional en
colombia en la que ha sido denominada
por el comité nacional de paro como la
toma de capitales y que ha producido
movilizaciones en todo el país
organizaciones denuncian que la
situación continúa siendo grave con más
de 60 muertos desde el inicio del paro
nacional el 28 de abril pero también más
de 3000 heridos y centenares de
desaparecidos estos números han llamado
la atención de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos que
ha solicitado al gobierno de iván duque
entrar en colombia para iniciar una
investigación algo que el ejecutivo ha
negado también aquí en la alcaldía de
claudia lópez en bogotá se ha enviado un
informe a las naciones unidas donde se
detallan más de 100 vulneraciones de los
derechos humanos claudia lópez quiere
volver a llevar la iniciativa como hizo
con la gestión de la pandemia al
presidente iván duque y es que ya ha
anunciado un plan de reestructuración
del presupuesto donde el dinero iría
destinado a temas sociales como
educación y transportes este miércoles
por lo tanto ha sido la antesala de lo
que será el próximo viernes cuando se
cumple un mes de paro nacional en
colombia